chers amis plus bonjour à tous pour ce
grand moment de la vie de notre
mouvement ce conseil national
exceptionnel dans quelques secondes
et bien vous allez découvrir les visages
de la liste qui va porter nos couleurs
aux élections européennes et j'appelle
sans plus tarder donc je vais commencer
comme aux césars par la fin de la liste
j'appelle sur scène les viagra cialis
anciaux alors les abattages avis
et leur terre neuve à nouveau de notre
famille politique pente en métropole que
sur l'île de beauté dont elle est
originaire elle est étudiante
responsable des jeunes en haute corse et
l'a décidé de s'engager avec toute
l'énergie de sa jeunesse à nos côtés
merci viviane j'appelle à plaisance
sébastien picard sébastien qui a un
parcours singulier l'issue de la société
civile entrepreneur à succès il a décidé
de faire vivre pleinement ses valeurs en
s'engageant en politique il est
aujourd'hui vice président du conseil
régional des pays de la loire où il a
notamment en charge la croissance bleue
l'innovation la recherche et
l'enseignement supérieur
bienvenue à toi cher sébastien sur cette
liste j'appelle post une manière festive
la jeunesse également 23 ans ancien
responsable des jeunes du pas de calais
faustine est désormais une de nos
candidates aux élections européennes un
parcours a montré en exemple puisqu'elle
a adhéré à notre famille politique à
l'âge de 16 ans
depuis elle est de tous les combats
fidèles
la fidélité que nous aimons dans notre
famille politique est plus qu une figure
du militantisme et est également une
élue reconnu au conseil régional des
hauts de france auquel elle est fière
d'appartenir bienvenue faustine
j'appelle à présent bernard carayon
bernard ancien député vert glamour dans
le tarn on a l'habitude
bernard et dévoué à sa ville à ses
concitoyens
et comme ceux qui le connaissent comme
moi vous savez que c'est un homme loyal
au franc-parler et épris de justice et
qui ne recule pas devant l'adversité il
est avocat mais il est aussi précurseur
du concept de patriotisme économique
bernard est un homme qui ne transige pas
avec nos valeurs nos valeurs bienvenue
bernard et merci à toi qu'on soit
françoise guégot avec qui j'ai eu le
plaisir d'être député sous la précédente
mandature cher françoise une vice
présidente du conseil régional de
normandie chargé de l'enseignement
supérieur aux côtés d'hervé de leroy
dont elle dit le plus grand bien à
tomber elle est également très engagée
sur les questions d'apprentissage et de
jeunesse est une femme de talent elle
est au coeur de l'action de la droite
sociale on a travaillé aux côtés de
laurent à la droite sociale chère
françoise très heureuse de te retrouver
tu incarnes la fidélité à laquelle nous
sommes tant attachés
j'appelle
philippe meunier sud iphone à
l'accord voté son fan-club chef philippe
un élu accompli qui a nous avons
également siégé sur les bancs de
l'assemblée lors de la dernière
mandature vice président aux côtés de
laurent il est chargé de la sécurité des
partenariats internationaux de la chasse
et de la pêche
c'est un homme qui compte on l'a entendu
à l'applaudimètre spécialiste des
questions de défense
voilà philippe c'est la compétence et la
rigueur c'est la passion on est fier de
te compter parmi nous
j'appelle à présent patrick boré patrick
homme du sud et de conviction qui a
donné un nouveau souffle à la ville de
la ciotat dont il est maire depuis dix
huit ans un homme de défi de projets un
homme passionné qui cultive la proximité
qui est premier vice président du
conseil départemental des bouches du
rhône il a à coeur de travailler pour
son département et pour sa région merci
patrick de rejoindre d'autres équipes
j'appelle un ruisseau anne conseillère
municipale et de long
lle méditerranée métropole anne est issu
du monde de l'entreprise on a besoin
d'entrepreneurs dans nos familles
politiques membres du mouvement les
centristes présidé par hervé morin a
rejoint notre intrépide porte de chaque
sensibilité et de sa connaissance du
territoire mexican de d'être à nos côtés
j'appelle guillaume guérin guillaume à
guillaume et abattant militants de
terrain qui croit que tout est possible
la preuve c'est qu'avec ses convictions
son travail son énergie il a arraché à
la gauche en 2014 avec l'équipe des 1000
roger lamberti la ville de limoges
c'était pas facile
une première pour notre famille
politique depuis 1912
j'examine il est également premier
adjoint au maire et vice président du
groupe plr au conseil régional de
nouvelles aquitaine président de notre
fédération en haute-vienne spécialisé
dans les questions agricoles
il incarne le renouveau bienvenue à toi
guillaume j'appelle à présent angélique
de l'allée angélique notre députée
européenne sortante et maire de saint
martin le beau en indre et loire
angélique est une femme courageuse
courageuse et l'occupent des mandats
mais elle conduit en même temps son
activité d'agricultrice dont elle est
évidemment une éminente représentante
elle a occupé et l'occupent d
et fonction importante elle est là était
une figure importante de la fnsea son
action et sa mobilisation en faveur des
agriculteurs aient connus reconnus
respectés nous comptons sur toi cher
angélique
c'est une chance de pouvoir compter sur
une agricultrice comme toi j'appelle à
présent bernard asso bernard fier de ses
racines de son identité niçoise
bernard est conseillé départementale des
alpes-maritimes et adjoint au maire de
nice
professeur de droit public passionné
d'histoire homme d'expérience attachés à
notre culture et nos traditions
je suis heureuse comme vous tous de
pouvoir compter sur son engagement dans
notre liste j'appelle à présent lydia
guirous c'est l'une des voix de notre
famille politique géré lydia vous pouvez
l'applaudir chaleureusement parce que
son combat courageux contre l'islam
radical en font une figure très
respectée de notre mouvement
on a besoin de femmes comme elle ya là
les convictions chevillées au corps et
qui n'a pas peur de les affirmer et
croyez-moi elle le fait malgré tout les
dangers qui rôdent un bolivien merci à
toi
j'appelle à présent alain cadec
cher alain alain lhomme de la mer
président de la commission de la pêche
au parlement européen c'est la voie de
la pêche et des du littoral à l'europe
et qui est fortement ancrée dans son
département les côtes d'armor et ce
territoire où il a grandi où il est né
eh bien il a à coeur de le défendre
il en est aujourd'hui le président du
conseil départemental son action en
particulier au service des marins
pêcheurs sera tout à fait déterminante
et ce sont de solides atouts que nous
avons avec la présence d'alain sur notre
liste mexia là
j'appelle christina stores est vive
christina nous la connaissons bien
elle travaille avec nous à l'assemblée
nationale elle est l'image de l'europe
franco italienne elle parle je crois
couramment quatre langues
ça sera utile à l'europe après avoir
exercé des responsabilités dans le
secteur privé
elle a choisi de s'engager en politique
à l'assemblée nationale et les
spécialistes des questions européennes
agricoles et environnementales mexique
russie n'a de nous rejoindre à j'appelle
froide pour cela
une autre figure de notre mouvement tant
à paris qu'à bruxelles député européen
sortant est également président de la
délégation française au groupe du ppe
cher joseph daul notre président un rôle
prépondérant dans l'animation et
l'action de nos partenaires européens
spécialiste des questions économiques
des questions commerciales
il est également un élu terrain dans le
gard son département et il occupe les
fonctions de premier adjoint au maire de
nîmes de vice président de nîmes
métropole
franck incarne les valeurs de compétence
de proximité et de fidélité merci mon
cher franck j'appelle à présent le vent
ça y est laurence on ne la présente plus
son visage sa voix sont connus de tous
depuis près d'un an et demi elle et sur
les plateaux matin midi soir nuit
quels que soient les événements a
commenté l et la fidl
fidèle au poste et elle défend avec la
vaillance qu'on lui connaît la famille
politique
et merci ma chère laurence pour ta
fidélité ta pugnacité tué une femme
courageuse et nous sommes très heureux
d'abord de ta présence dans l'équipe
dirigeante j'ai beaucoup de plaisir à
travailler avec toi comme avec tous les
membres de l'équipe dirigeante mais
voilà bienvenue à toi sur cette liste
donc que tu saura défendre avec
l'énergie qu'on te connais frédéric
péchenard vous connaissez tous frédéric
une éminente une éminente figure de
notre mouvement
ancien directeur général des
républicains vice-président du conseil
régional d'ile-de-france conseiller de
paris ancien directeur général de la
police nationale excusez du peu
il dispose d'une expérience d'une
expertise qui font de lui un spécialiste
des questions de sécurité de lutte
contre le terrorisme est évidemment face
à ces gens en jeu la présence de
frédéric sera tout à fait utile dans
notre liste merci mon cher frédéric de
ta présence de ton engagement à nos
côtés à ressembler la chère anne je te
connais bien parce que du temps regretté
où nos listes étaient régional tu es une
des députés de ma région et tuée
souvenant souvent venu sur le terrain tu
es une femme de terrain de conviction de
coeur et je suis très heureuse de ta
présence tué vice présidente de la
fédération du bas-rhin
tu es députée européenne sortante tu
évidemment ta région entretient une
relation tout à fait privilégiée avec
l'europe et tu es en charge des
questions économiques et monétaires
tu as eu l'occasion de t'engager contre
la criminalité fiscale qui est un fléau
pour pour notre continent était
compétent sur ces sujets seront à
nouveau très utile merci ma chère alain
j'appelle à présent geoffroy didier
secrétaire général délégué des
républicains voilà un de mes secrétaires
généraux délégués avec guillaume larrivé
geoffroy et député européen vice
président du conseil régional d'île de
france en charge de l'attractivité du
logement de la rénovation urbaine où il
a une véritable expertise et il
travaille beaucoup sur les questions
liées à l'emploi aux affaires sociales
dans le cadre de son mandat européen
c'est extrêmement utile à un moment où
parle d'harmonisation sociale et chaque
jour tant à bruxelles qu'à paris dans
les médias il défend les républicains et
nos propositions
avec le talent et le calme qu'on lui
connaît bravo cher jeu fera très
heureuse de travailler avec toi et de te
voir
au sein de cette liste et j'appelle à
présent nathalie colin oesterlé voilà
cher nathalie tué vice président du
conseil départemental de moselle tu es
une spécialiste des questions de
développement économique et d'emplois tu
représentes le mouvement des centristes
au sein de notre ligue on peut
l'applaudir
elle contribue elle est la belle image
du rassemblement de notre famille
politique
merci nathalie de ta confiance et
bienvenue sur cette liste
j'appelle à présent brice hortefeux
cher bruce
chez reprise tuer non seulement député
européen ancien ministe vice président
de la région qui nous accueillent
aujourd'hui ton expertise ton expérience
sont connus de tous sur les questions
économiques comme en matière de sécurité
alors que la place de la france et
chaque jour remise en cause que le
président de la république nous isole un
peu plus chaque jour de nos partenaires
européens et internationaux
nous pouvons compter sur brice sur son
expérience sur son aura pour retisser
ces liens voilà et puis il s'est
vraiment une figure majeure avec
laquelle il est toujours bon d'échangé
parce qu'il a un regard d'une acuité qui
est très précieuse dans notre famille
merci cher brice
j'accueille présent nadine morano
voilà
je ne vais pas vous présenter nadine une
fidèle fidèles passionnés proche de nos
adhérents qu'elle connaît depuis de
nombreuses années elle est un exemple de
loyauté et d'engagement
tous ici savent combien elles portent
nos convictions chevillées au corps
députée européenne ancienne ministre
femme de terrain présidente de la
fédération de meurthe et moselle
elle continuera je le sais à faire
entendre sa voix et celle des
républicains à strasbourg et à bruxelles
nous en avons besoin bras bruna d'humour
facho
et puis comme pour les césars le moment
attendu de la présentation de notre trio
cher arnaud danjean viens nous rejoindre
député européen
sonos est une référence en matière de
défense de sécurité de diplomatie et son
expertise et son expérience sont connus
de tous
au coeur des ministères comme celui de
la défense des affaires étrangères
il a représenté la france lors de crises
comme celle des balkans ou d'afghanistan
la présence de ce bourguignon c'est ma
région
ancien conseiller régional en troisième
position est un atout pour notre liste
moi je voudrais vous dire que suis
particulièrement heureuse d'accueillir
arnaud parce que je les souvent
accueillis dans ma région j'ai pu
constater à quel point ces interventions
étaient toujours extrêmement précise et
toujours très appréciée c'est vraiment
la compétence
donc nous avons un grand besoin est une
figure éminente de notre de notre liste
bravo arnaud bienvenue à toi annonce
cher au mieux
cher agnès agneaux c'est vrai le vice
présidente de la région ile de france
une passionnée une élu passionné engagé
qui a qui préside à présent la
fédération de paris dont j'ai pu voir
d'ailleurs l'efficacité cette semaine au
siège on ne savait plus où mettre les
adhérents tant qu'ils étaient nombreux
bravo cher agnès et puis elle incarne le
seul usage de la nouvelle droite
une jeune femme engagée et qui portera
la voix de la culture parce que l'europe
c'est aussi l'europe de la culture et de
la civilisation ce sont des sujets qui
te sont chers et qui me le sont
également merci agnès bravo à tous et
puis bien sûr chez lui qui à carde notre
liste notre tête
oui enfin se lever pour l'accueillir et
l'applaudît françois xavier était la
mine
françois-xavier bellamy votre tête de
liste et lui et lui tend une des grandes
villes d'ile-de-france philosophes
écrivains engagés à nos côtés
via lille
la force des convictions la clarté
lumineuse de l'expression il est le
visage du renouveau de notre famille
politique
avec une équipe comme celle là nous
allons déjoué les pronostics faire
mentir les sondages et faire un tabac
pour ces élections européennes
[Applaudissements]
alors les amis regardez tous de là bas
parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui veulent
une photo de famille donc vous avez
trois secondes
voilà pour sourire
centriste il faut leur faire une
éducation merci à vous tous alors voilà
si vous êtes comme moi enthousiasmés par
les propos d'anne et derrick et les
choix qui ont été faits si cette équipe
ou combien vous me montrez un carton
bleu
japonais
c'est tout fleurs et hélas compte tenu
de cette liste hervé morin le bleu au
coeur voilà bah écoute et il sait tout
bleu donc cette liste est validé voilà
pause deuxième vote
est-ce que vous acceptez que la
commission nationale d'investitures
éminemment présidé par eric ciotti
terminent la liste jusqu'à la fin carton
bleu lâche un peu directif là mais voilà
on a mangé un peu de temps et bien voilà
eric la responsabilité de faire en sorte
que cette équipe s'étoffe encore et
qu'elle puisse apporter effectivement au
bout la victoire
merci aux coûts restent avec nous reste
avec moi sur la scène françois xavier
agnès arnaud qui vont vous présenter le
projet